Received patient for care at 07:30 PM.
Came to say hi to patient
but patient said
you better get the fuck out of this room
before I hit you with my IV pole.
Nurse laughing
came back 30 minutes after
patient refused to take his medication
and said that I am a drug dealer.
Patient proceed to call 911 to have me arrested
for giving the medication he's been taking for 30 years.
Police arrived at around 12 am to arrest me
and Peter requested
I get handcuffed in front of his room.
I am finally
able to give the patient medication at one am
after belly dancing as per patient request,
otherwise he will refuse again.
The patient was assisted to the bathroom
time swan and climbing the ceiling at 3 am
and left the note that he will go
find the missing bladder scanner off the unit
because he heard the dayship
nurses are crying because they cannot find it.
Securities in the ceiling
at the moment.
Patients have to be found and the advice
family will be made aware.
Will continue to monitor.